when mobile browsers first came along
the content on web wasn't designed for
narrow small screen devices it was
designed for Windows that were around a
thousand pixels wide and wider than they
were tall with easy scrolling to
shoehorn this content into a tiny mobile
screen since rendering a web page
designed for a thousand pixels across on
a 320 pixel wide screen would mean you'd
be scrolling a lot mobile browsers
basically lied about the window width
they made the window act as if it were
980 pixels wide even though the original
iPhone was only 320 pixels across this
enabled sites that were designed for a
1024 by 768 screen that is that were
around 980 pixels wide to fit on the
mobile screen although you needed to do
a lot of zooming to read the text
sometimes unfortunately if your site did
not happen to match that 980 pixel width
you were either going to overflow or
underflow the screen either wasting
space or forcing the user to zoom in
order to control this Apple provided a
viewport meta tag to be added to your
HTML to control the default for how big
should my screen act on this page the
default is 980 so if you put 980 here it
would have no effect the mobile browser
already defaults to 980 but setting a
viewport tells the browser how wide the
content is intended to be and then the
browser scales to make that size fit on
the devices screen there are two ways to
use this tag